what's happening there reject nation greg
and john here today we just got out of the
premiere for the movie light year john i picked
up one of these two at the after party i gave
mine away to a little kid who wasn't able to get
one i took mine from a little kid who was so all
these people who think john's nicer than me no i'm
just getting away more humble and i think it shows
your humbleness is off the charts right now my
guy it's been a while since we've seen like one
of the trailers for this film but i was really
much looking forward to it now i want to get
this out of the way there's a lot of things that
people debate about this one thing to debate is
should you guys hit the like button on this video
yes you absolutely should i definitely think you
should help us out in the algorithm secondly
what exactly is this movie is it a prequel is
it based off a real life astronaut i feel like
i've always had it right and john's had a very
different point of view again john i'm much more
humble than you to say that i was right can you
please tell me what it was because i still don't
know this movie makes it abundantly clear at the
very top of the film this movie could have saved
us a lot of confusion putting it in the trailer
there i know it's really the literal first thing
on screen universe is the context basically what
they set up is that there is a movie that andy
watched that is about buzz lightyear and then
the toys that you watch that he plays with with
buzz lightyear and zerg and all that that is
based off of the movie that andy watched so it's
like an in-universe film that you're watching
with that in mind i i was kind of wondering very
early on it took a little bit of adjusting could
i really get into this movie though because it
made me so aware at the very top that this is
a fake piece of fiction this is a movie i know
that sounds silly and stupid because toy story
is obviously a piece of fiction but this is
a movie within a franchise yeah yeah and it's
it's drawing attention to itself that this is not
real maybe the stakes won't feel real but i gotta
say that i really think this movie actually very
much delivered so this film in a lot of ways is a
big blend a splice of a whole bunch of different
space sci-fi opera films that you've seen before
things like interstellar gravity star trek star
wars 2001 a space odyssey alien the best way i can
describe the way they handled this space sci-fi
genre was the way i felt with incredibles how they
did the superhero genre pixar of wow they managed
to do like a great animated medium version of a
superhero genre and do things that you couldn't
normally do in a superhero film i thought that
they did that here but also keeping it very family
friendly and at times heart wrenching but always
full of wonder a lot of existential themes we'll
get into the plot in a little bit you want to tell
them i imagine do we echo the same i think we do
yeah we want to tell what the plot of this movie
is actually about the plot of the movie within the
movie yes within the movie basically buzz light
you're the titular hero is on a mission to fix
a mistake he made that basically strands all of
star command or at least his unit on this desert
planet that is very hostile and then from there
beyond that come zerg and other threats to deal
with he has to challenge himself as well as his
young group of cadets to rise to the occasion and
save the day and hopefully complete the mission
get everybody back home yeah you know in the movie
interstellar movie's a few years old so slightly
ruining the plot of interstellar for you guys
what is that version of time travel called uh time
not dilation time dilation this time dilution yeah
where if you're traveling at a different rate in
time time moves differently for you than it does
for other people yet that painful experience of oh
my god i i've missed out on a few years although
my loved ones around me have aged and the trailers
do show that that is what he goes through
in this film one thing i thought that was so
wonderful about this film of how they capture
their characters is that so much of the way
the plot unfolds is the protagonist making just
human errors human mistakes from trying to do the
right thing yeah it's always that one little
thing you missed yeah it's not just with buzz
lightyear uh who by the way is is great in this
film i think chris evans did an exceptional job
at capturing the essence that we knew and loved
from what tim allen did with the toy version of
buzz lightyear but he truly makes it his own like
it's very easy to distinguish the two of them and
the fact that they do space travel in here my
mind did drift off for a split second going
oh man because he did some like weird multiverse
thing where he goes to the real world right where
he goes into like andy's world specifically than
our real world like buzz lightyear from toy story
tim allen shows up yeah i think that would be a
really awesome film and i i do think that he did
such a great job here a big part of what they
set up with his character is his struggle to
be able to cooperate and work with others his
ability to accept help feeling like he always
has to kind of do everything on his own he has
trust issues not that they really dive into the
background of that but that is such a core essence
of this character and i think it's another movie
that's great for the family and i think easily
easily the standout character though we haven't
even discussed it but i'm just going to throw you
know who is it it's it sucks sock out of me sucks
yeah the most adorable supporting character and
i mean disney pixar they are known for these
kinds of marketable supporting characters but
hey they knock it out of the park again socks
is so much fun a very useful character but also
a character with a huge amount of personality
and really rounds out the ensemble for sure
usually a bit cynical whenever a character like
that shows up at first like oh here we go the
toy yeah it's like literally a cute merchandise
it's a robotic cat so i'm like you've designed
merch now to sell congratulations disney and
as i say cynically while attending your premiere
thank you mickey mouse easily like the crowd you
could tell just fell in love with this character
and it was seriously the best part of the film i i
actually would be like no yeah sucks
was the best part of the movie to me
yeah there's a in a movie filled with good stuff
and a lot of great uh really enjoyable characters
and voice performances yeah i mean socks is
a scene stealer absolutely and as you see in
the trailer again i'm referencing the trailer
has to make sure not to spoil because there's a
lot of big plot things in this movie that are not
revealed in the trailer in the trailer as you see
that when you start this movie off with buzz
lightyear uh his partner space ranger hawthorne
is his partner his best friend and then as he gets
a little bit more into the future now he's dealing
with the granddaughter he's the granddaughter
played by kiki palmer both kiki palmer or
he's only the granddaughter kiki bomb uzo duba i
believe is alicia the grandmother his best friend
and then yeah kiki palmer is uh her granddaughter
izzy well both characters are wonderful it's the
really great move to me yeah there are all sorts
of reasons people roll their eyes like oh yeah
spunky young female astronaut or whatever but
yeah like their friendship was so endearing and
tangible and then the relationship that unfolds
with izzy the granddaughter and you know the
more sort of workplace struggles that they face as
they try to solve these intergalactic problems set
before them yeah like there's a lot of really
wonderful growth there are moments especially
featuring those characters in their relationship
to buzz that made me emotional and made me tear up
even during scenes that were also involving action
and you know heavy stakes and whatnot i mean i'm
glad you brought the action because this is some
of the best action pixar has done it's like do i
think that the fight scenes are as good as the
incredibles i wouldn't necessarily say that but
it's very different it's it's all sci-fi space
stuff you know bugs aliens lasers a lot of great
camera movements i would say that this is one of
the more intense pixar movies there are sequences
in here that are just flat out suspenseful and you
do get that awe-inspiring space travel experience
and it's pretty existential film you know yeah
it manages to do what i think a lot of great
space travel sci-fi even action sci-fi movies do
while never feeling like it's pandering too young
and never feeling like it's aiming way above
anybody like it really has yes some sci-fi
themes some existential themes a lot of great
character humor and beats and a you know big high
concept story yeah yeah it's not like the more
reflective sci-fi thing that wall-e was which but
it's got shades of that it's got no that's i mean
it has like contextual exploration of those things
but the the vibe is very space adventure yeah
absolutely and i think they do a really wonderful
like this is out of a pixar movies and b just
animated movies right now this was the most i sort
of lost the line between watching an animated film
and watching just a live-action movie like even
just the melding of chris evans voice with the
animation of that character but even further you
mentioned like the camera work and i know there's
been a big debate in movie culture recently about
how do we credit cinematographers in you know
these big cg movies because people think oh it's
just effects animators but no like cinematography
is a huge part of it and there's so many really
amazing camera choices lens choices lighting
choices that really bring this to life and
make you feel like you're watching a real
movie which is a weird thing to say because
it is a real movie but yeah it makes you feel like
you're watching a live action movie and you exist
in the animated realm needless to say like the
music is also great i think there's a couple of
supporting characters that took a little bit of
time for me to warm up to but eventually you do
and uh yeah i don't really have an issue with this
film i'd actually say i want to watch this again
on imax yeah and i could have watched it for for
10 or 15 minutes longer and this is the first time
in a long time i thought i want to see that in 3d
yeah there's some really great scope well guys the
film delivered don't know what else to say thank
you guys so much for being here because yeah this
was uh absolutely fast thank you guys subscribe
click that bell and we'll talk to you guys soon
lance door door buddy listen man we asked each
other who would we want to go to space with and
you know what we decided who our patreon
would be fun to go to space with lance
tell them why john lance oh my god in space where
clearly strength means everything you would be the
person to command our intergalactic mission we
would go to infinity and beyond because of your
leadership lance door leadership you would not
make any mistakes whatsoever and that's what i
love about you is just your unhuman levels
of perfection lance i just want you to know
how much i hold you on this pedestal alright space
the wonders of the cosmos screw all that buddy
all right it's all about that beautiful tanned
canadian i know called lance canadians in space
space canadians and the uh the the
world of the great white beyond
uh yeah man so hey he's if he's a fighter now
he could be a firefighter maybe a space fighter
how cool would lance look putting out a fire
in some kind of like spaceship corridor yeah
yeah it would be cool it'd be sexy it must
be a great way to get away from that family
once and for all yeah all right lance in
space no one can be like hey what about us
your life yeah rocks best ass restaurants
provide for us and be emotionally stories
of people being like i got to be away from my
family this heartbreaking but what if there
was a story about one who was like i'm going to
seriously get away much better i didn't even want
to go to space but now that i'm up here i don't
have to talk to any of those people a few lamps